allora mi ero dimenticato di fare la
intro per questo video e quindi ve la
faccio qui in questo momento mentre sono
in gita siamo su total e accurate batte
ground che quel gioco bellissimo che
avevo fatto con il signor gatto tipo un
paio di settimane fa e questa volta
siamo con thomas
ovviamente se vinciamo in merito è mio
che bello è il mio personaggio mi dicono
fosse così bello se però andò a allora
ti spiego come si gioca perché questo è
un gioco per chi gli e sport se ne
intende allora in partenza noi non siamo
assolutamente vicini che può veramente
che si sta strisciando una sopra l'altra
perché sono tutti i simpatici nella
lobby non ci incontreremo mai perché si
schiacciato se siamo veramente distanti
scusa primi tablet cosa venisse primi
tablet vedo io la mattina quando mi sono
dimenticato di montare il video prendono
uno ff voli tantissimo quindi puoi
andare sul par cavalca c'è un tizio qua
milioni non morire subito tipo che ci
sta sparando là dietro però non dovesse
farcela seguendo si sta seguendo via via
e vai vai vai vai tar in corso al più
adrenalinica del mondo è un 48 un fucile
sulle rocce a caso ho trovato anche una
corona come si chiama non so parlar
gioco tanti allora poi non so se hai
visto come si chiude la zona l'hai visto
no come se la zona si chiude che cadono
queste colonne dal cielo si sentano per
terra e si apre proprio un muro è
fighissimo
eccoti qua ci sono nel veicolo certi c'è
un vecchio ruba salih sali per essere
dietro dietro stadi dietro a o caroteni
che gli altri un po meno corna in questo
momento che magari sono meno visibili a
posto spalare ma non posso prendere la
mira o che ho capito è esatto ma perché
stiamo su una bici anche io posso
superare dal guidatore
io sto pedalando senza pedalare ma seta
b adesso ti vedi che stai facendo
movimento della bicicletta o è fermato
persona vedo seduto malissimo però
guidato bravo bravo così tom sinistro
belle ste gambe quando riguardano
pantani
io vedo me senso ha dire gatto mi vedo
da solo nome nella casa più trash del
mondo sta giochi e siamo a big match
secondo me qua c'è gente però va bene
vai tranquillo ti vuole mai ci credo io
prima partita prima vittoria
stanno sparando dove da te te ne faccio
uno saprete saprete aspetto
cavagna c gente qualcuno dietro tanto
meno schiacciano no da dietro come da
dietro dai prima partita prima vittoria
da ingenui che corrono tagli chi le
corna tibre sei mesi la se ti sdrai per
terra ti vedono ovunque siamo vicini
corri verso di me eccolo cavolo non era
mica grande tra qualcuno 30 secondi
abbiamo se ne dicon troviamo toccarci
perfetto si prenda legnate e bellissimo
luce qualcosa là c'è una visione con le
luci ma perché kanemoto loro tonino una
moto è la moto sia un albero col naso
perché venga aspetta debbo in tre napa
l'eolica lo sapevo che roba bellissimo
destro madonna che mallett io ho visto
andare fortissimo contro non c'è niente
non c'è l'occhio pardon parlato passò
circa la sua filati che ci passo ci
parla aspetta aspetta aspetta magari
marino scendono cento aspetto che
aspetto di entrarci a 200 all'ora guarda
poi secondo me era un po piccolino cosa
ho visto delle robe strane ma ci siamo
passati l'ora di armi ci sei
sono morto quasi morto
[Musica]
ma come sei morto è lunga la testa
contro la ringhiera e sono morte le
maniche signore così ma di volte ma non
è vero
sei morto tanto non possiamo atterrare
davanti tranquillo mi si allunga al
collo cosa si cela sua faccia è stata
bellissima la tua riesce è stata
preziosa
ecco su una fascia dove andiamo a caos
ma siamo dalle parti diverse lav e ti
raggiungerò in qualche modo
insomma sembrava fossi partito da
un'altra parte maledizione magari
raggiungeva le valuta ma la macchinone
ieri prima cosa vedo non facciamo
domande che ti guardo entrare come dire
ok sto facendo qui sta puntando stai
facendo tu stai facendo stare
esattamente stretching o non m60 in mano
un elicottero
poi vai vai subito ma non sapevo
esistesse parla veloce vele con agricola
torre lo sapremo mai
forse la cascata nell'altro l'hanno
incastrato si prova a spostarlo con la
macchina noi voglio voglio vederlo
ringrazio anch'io spostato la matrice
sparerò usa mi sa che erano le eliche
che sbattevano contro dover aspettare
forse no luca neri che ci stanno
imparando si adatta alla dalla roccia
della nostra ok non sono già 105 diamo
ad arcene non si può muovere
l'elicottero salta 60 60 su chi sei e
chi no
allora non c'era mai k scappa va detto
il presidente romano per cui non sei un
prestatore in aria la macchina la fuga
bello salta fuori
ok dopo il salto fuori anch'io sono
stato fuori rischiare la macchina che
arriva occhio nascondiamoci dove siamo
arrivati noi riesci a coprirmi n'attimo
aspetto occhio fisso ma che te lo fa
inforcava mano perché è uno scudo dietro
lo scudo ma lady che vediamo nella foto
una bara di colpi e non ho più colpire
no cav h sono trovi o degli scudi delle
porte proprio che ti puoi mettere sulla
schiena si servono un sacco
abbiamo una zona incasinata allora esca
capire come come ammazzarlo porca vacca
di schianto
magari siamo in 2000 comincia la mia
cosa vedo che è un bombardamento
la guerra dei mondi lista sinistra si
sta con la mini non è da meno ok madonna
come si sparerà guarda quanta gente
appare comunque vada la composta da
sparare dai sarà guarda buon questo c'è
la bce che risalgono che io sopra e
decorosa non mi sa che ho sbagliato
vai vai vai veloce che attendere la sola
città è perché poi c'è gente che spara
fortissimo non morire ed ogni oblio h
che male che sono io dove sono i veri
qua per in tutto veloce per terra la
porta compresa
e un po quello mettitelo dietro
l'equipaggio sta bene così siamo qua
dentro
no no
in questo momento e hukic il cgie
degenti questa casa nei tratti a doppio
a destra per marca vacca c'è un
messicano gli ho sparato forte 1 niente
messicano al piano di sopra c'è un
messicano non ho niente contro i
messicani neanche abitato da matti ha
ora stanno uscendo dal retro 1 st pil
cosa ovvia è svenuto ragazza è ancora
vivo e vabbè il mortale
ok e quanto a te l'ha data la kill tema
la farà a me non mi dice quando tu
racconti d'achille va beh siamo
fortunati o mio dio stranieri gente ma
questi ma come mero noti in da quattro
prendo la macchina
prendiamo ha preso io
ottimo avevo mai stai guidando per fare
con il ministro tra l'altro una milligan
io andrei non vorresti mai vedermi
sparare con questo giudizio scientifici
sistema dove dovrebbe arrivare a
mitragliare non morirà dove il tipo
desktop
dall'altro lato sinistro o che c'è altra
gente e sarà entrato in una casa
la safety ha superato dobbiamo andar da
nova lentissima ma non è un profilo del
tipo dove cominciano da mamma mia mamma
mia
niente la miniserie via riva starr ma
che [ __ ] abbiamo potuto dar migliore
insomma non fuggire fortissimo tom ford
ma do mai passato punto
che ci facciamo si schianteranno per
consentirgli adesso andiamo via di
quadri di fare dico aperto live occhio
non te ne andare giù bravo mi devo
assolutamente curare siamo ci si dà alle
rocce così mi facci qua live e occhio
vado io guido io no vai vai vai vai
prodi a carico proviamo light tom ha
capito dagli agenti a gli alberelli
mettiamoci poi si stanno sparando di
sana pianta di loro io cioè il mio
braccio che mi copre la visuale come
faccio a sparare perché ho le armi
storte ma perché stavo facendo beatbox
fi beatboxer mi sort mi chiama tra
l'altro questi sparano come se
giocassero gioco da una vita com'è
possibile
madonna ma incredibile li mettono come
fanno mai per nova baseball non è
possibile se uno va sopra lucito grande
ne manca uno solo a destra destra dove
986 da solo vieni qua ad amare il 21 si
è scoperto ma eccola e mi sarei curato
volentieri prima cura tv le tv la tv
reticolati limiti sia dietro a quanto
muore come e tirato giù infatti curati
però non è vero hai poi verso tre quinti
dai due contro uno comprendiamo online
occhio occhio dove vai
si passerà da carlos ha detto no ma no
il dritto dritto dritto 4
io non so se lo sto colpendo
effettivamente però ci sto provando op
si chiude a ci sta cavolo si sta
chiedendo che cosa che andiamo tutti al
baretto ti al baretto in vico tori i
grandissimi victoria giustamente siamo
stati bravi dai poteva andar peggio si
sia sentita di andare molto peggio ti
apprezzo
mi piace questa risultanza di vittoria
alla ti piace totali arcore i batteri di
roma spera quindi se video vi è piaciuto
ragazzi conosciuto lasciate un commento
mi piace anche lì secondo la descrizione
non sempre siete ci vediamo
fermo
[Musica]